Heute im Rasenfunk?
Tentu Kian Mbappé.
Kian!
Irgendwann habe ich meine Gäste in der Liga Tour soweit, dass sie oberkörperfrei die Tore ihres jeweiligen Landes bejubeln. So ist es jetzt schon fast für alle, die uns bei YouTube sehen. Die haben schon die Andeutung davon gemerkt. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen hier im Rasenfunk in der Liga Tour. Wir wollen sprechen über die europäischen Top-League bei den Männern. Und dazu begrüße ich bei mir David Frangier de Pont-le-Vain für die Ligue 1. Hallo David.
Im offensiven Mittelfeld, ist das richtig? Also keine Stürme? Na, da kennt man ja aber auch gar keine Vereine, die da suchen.
Max, darf ich dein Wigen-Dingsbums-Symbolzeichen aufgreifen? Ich habe nämlich einen Unsung-Hero, ist er nicht, aber schon ein kleinen Hero, nämlich geschichtsträchtigen Hero, fast unter den Tisch fallen lassen. Vergessen, Lamine Jamal, der Barca-Superstar im Upcoming, mit 16 Jahren, der jüngste Torschütze La Liga geworden beim 2. Tor gegen Granada. Hätte ich fast unter den Tisch fallen lassen. Ist natürlich bemerkenswert. Der ist nicht Unsung. Man hat ihn mittlerweile besungen, natürlich, weil er der Shootingstar schlechthin ist. Aber das erste Mal eben getroffen jetzt gegen Granada. Und mit, lass mich nachgucken, 16 Jahre und 87 Tagen, jüngste Torschütze in der Geschichte der Primärer Division. Genau, hat einen langfristigen Vertrag bekommen. Ist natürlich schon Nationalspieler. Hat auch bei der Nationalmannschaft schon getroffen, wie man es halt mit 16 Jahren so macht. Also absolut bemerkenswert. Hat jetzt nicht ganz, ich habe zu starkköpfig in diese Kategorien gedacht, nicht ganz in das Unsung Hero Kategorie gepasst, weil man ihn einfach schon kennt. Aber allein dieser Rekord, das wäre töricht, wenn ich den hier nicht erwähne, ne?
Ja, absolut. Töricht ist da auch genau das Attektiv, was mir eigentlich gefallen wäre. Marius, dann machen wir noch MVP und Momente Spieltags.
Ist eigentlich beides relativ offensichtlich. Dafür MVP Lau Toro Martínez. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, der wurde mir vorgelegt. Ich komme eigentlich meistens nicht.
Aber bitte sag mir, dass man das in italienischen Medien nicht wirklich auch macht.
Also sein Spitzname ist der Toro, das übersetzt sich dann natürlich nicht so gut. Aber ich habe den, also es gibt der Rete Gi bei Napoli und Rete ist das Tor. Ich habe das noch nicht gelesen. Und eigentlich ist das so offensichtlich. Aber vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach ausgeblendet.
Nee, ich glaube, dafür haben italienische Vereine zu viel Stil. Diese Lewandowski-Nummer usw., das machen halt deutsche Vereine.
Ja, Martinez, 10 Tore in 8 Spielen, Viererpack gegen das Hellenitana, trägt Inter nach den Abgängen von Lukaku und Dzeku quasi allein auf seinen Schultern. Mit Markus Thüram übrigens, Superduo. Thüram glänzt als Vorbereiter meistens, hat schon 7 Assists und Martinez verwandelt halt und auch aus jeder Lage. Ja, das, was er bei der WM für Argentinien verschossen hat, das holt er jetzt irgendwie nach und das finde ich schon sehr beeindruckend. Und der Moment des Spieltags, der gebührt Olivier Giroud, natürlich, wir haben ihn den sexiest goalkeeper alive genannt.
Warum freut sich David da so sehr?
Ja, weil es auch in den französischen Medien eine unglaublich große Story war. Es kamen jetzt auch noch Sachen, ich weiß gar nicht, hat man das in Deutschland mitbekommen? Es war ja der unglaubliche insgesamt so.
Ich glaube schon, dass das in den deutschen Medien schon überall aufgegriffen wurde.
Ja, es war aber nur so eine kleine... Also ich habe es mitbekommen. War das jetzt im Spiel gegen Genoa, wo er ins Tor musste? Also eben für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. Mignon sieht rot und weil das Auswechselkontingent schon ausgeschöpft ist, streift sich Olivier Giroud. Die Torhüterhandschuhe über, geht ins Tor für sogar durchaus noch ein paar Minuten. Das war ja dann... Und ich glaube, er musste auch hin und wieder eingreifen.
Er hat eine richtige Parade, wo er so mit dem Arm nach vorne geht. Da gibt es jetzt auch ein kleines Video, weil die Nationalmannschaft zusammengekommen ist, wo er mit den Trainern steht und dann ihnen erzählt, dass er da einen blauen Fleck hat von der ganzen Nation. Und Guy Stéphane, der eine Co-Trainer, sagt dann, ja, aber weißt du, was ich besonders beeindruckt von dir fand, war, wie du mit den Augen nach einer Ecke geschaut hast. Und da hat man gemerkt, dass du richtig... Und ich hab jetzt auch gehört, anscheinend hat der Verein ja jetzt auch das Trikot von Giroud in den Online-Shop gestellt, also als Torhütertrikot.
Obwohl er nicht mal daraus Kapitalschlangen ist, ja klar.
Wurde er nicht von der Serie A in die Mannschaft des Spieltags als Torhüter gewählt oder war das...
Ich glaube, zumindest in irgendeinem, irgendwo auch, ja, hab ich auch schon das gesehen.
Also, kleines Gmbick, ne?
Der Jan Koller oder Michael Thanat, der Serie A.
Ich erinnere mich, daran erinnern sich die Älteren.
Ich hab bei Transfermarkt so eine Umfrage-Grafik gebaut mit wer hat's am besten gemacht und ich hab mich nicht an Michael Thanat erinnert.
Dabei hat er sogar noch einen Schuss, der dann abgepfiffen war, aber den hat er aus dem Eck rausgeholt.
Vielleicht ist er zu jung, der arme Marius. Einen Verziehen.
Nee, ich hab das damals schon gesehen, aber kam nicht.
Es sei dir verziehen. Also Olivier Giroud zwischen den Pfosten vom AC Milan. Das ist ein sehr schöner Moment des Spieltags. Ich hatte ihn nämlich schon wieder vergessen. Danke, dass das wieder herauskommt.
Im wahrsten Sinne ein schöner Moment.
Aber wir wollen ja nicht so oberflächlich sein. Weder bei Frauen noch bei Männern. In der Ligue 1, was haben wir denn da noch offen, David? Wenn ich es richtig sehe, MVP und Moment.
Der Moment wird allerdings nicht so schön. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, ob ich das vorziehe, damit wir nicht auf so einem Downer enden. Also im Moment, außergewöhnlicher Moment des Spieltags, hat sich beim Spiel Montpellier gegen Clément ereignet. Montpellier hatte einen vergleichsweise okayen Saisonstart. Die stehen aber, wenn ihr auf die Tabelle schaut, aktuell mit einem Spiel weniger da. Weil das Spiel wurde abgebrochen. Die haben 4 zu 2 geführt. Die haben sich zurückgekämpft wieder. Die standen sogar noch mit 10 Mann auf dem Feld. Und es läuft hier Nachspielzeit. Und es sieht alles danach aus, als ob das ein ganz großartiger Abend für Montpellier ist, die sich noch auf die Schulter klopfen können. Und da sagen können, super, haben wir geschafft. Und dann wirft ein Fan einen Böller, und zwar einen ziemlich großen, Clémence Torwart Murray Dior, vor die Füße. Und zwar wirklich vor die Füße. Und der explodiert, der kippt zusammen, muss auf der Trage weggebracht werden. Was schön ist, ist, dass die Ultras tatsächlich direkt, da kann man auf den Bildern auch sehen, in eine Richtung zeigen. Also auf den Mann zeigen. Der wurde auch verhaftet mittlerweile. Der gehört anscheinend auch keiner Ultra-Gruppierung an. Sei angeblich zu betrunken gewesen, um ihn zu verhören an dem Tag. Ja, aber es steht zu befürchten, dass A Montpellier nicht nur dieses Spiel, das sie sich da erkämpft haben, verlieren wird, sondern dass sie auch noch mit Punktabzug bestraft werden, weil in einem ähnlichen Fall als ein Böller mal in Richtung Spieler geflogen ist. Ich glaube, bei Metz war das. Da gab es auch zwei Punkte Abzug. Das ist der Präsident Nicolas, der Junge, also nicht der aus der Meistermannschaft damals, hat auch bereits sich sehr deutlich vor die Kameras gestellt und mehr oder weniger gesagt, das ist ein Arschloch.
Wie geht es dem Torhüter?
Der scheint wieder in Ordnung zu sein. Ich glaube, der ist sogar zum Nationalteam abgereist. Ich meine, ich was gehört zu haben.
Verwechselst du es jetzt nicht mit Olivier Giroud?
Nein.
Sorry, der lag zu nahe.
Ja, der war klar. Ich muss kurz schauen. Ist ja auch egal. Aber es geht ihm definitiv besser.
Genau, darum geht es. Das ist ja auch sehr gut. Dann schauen wir, was da bei Montpellier passiert. Das wiederum habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Danke, David. Und wer ist denn dann der MVP aktuell?
Senegal ist er übrigens. Er ist Torhüter des Senegalen. Im Nationalteam. Mein MVP ist, das habe ich vorhin schon kurz geteasert, kommt aus der Monaco-Mannschaft. Das ist Ismael Jacobs. Der ist der Bundesliga-Ismael Jacobs.
Ex-Kölner, oder?
Falls du Vergleiche haben möchtest. Genau, Ex-Kölner. Er hat ein Tor, eine Vorlage beigesteuert beim 3-1 gegen eine durchaus überzeugende Mannschaft aus Reims. Die muss das sehr, sehr, glaube ich, geärgert haben, dass Balogun, der vergangene Saison an sie ausgeliehen war, von Arsenal, hatte ich berichtet hier in der Liga Tour. Der spielt ja jetzt bei Monaco, hat gegen sie jetzt geknipst. Und Monaco ist einfach nach wie vor bernstark unter Bällenführer. Und Ismael Jakobs ist eigentlich gar nicht Stammspieler aktuell. Der durfte mal von Anfang an ran. Das heißt, Adi Hütte hat auch noch, hat nicht nur eine geile Mannschaft zurzeit, sondern auch noch Auswahl. Das sieht schon richtig gut aus. Und deswegen ja auch mein Hinweis könnte Spaß machen da am nächsten Spieltag, die mal zu sehen. Hab 21 Tore schon geschossen, ein Tor weniger als der VfB.
Also ich muss sagen, diese Worts, die machen mir unheimliche Freude, dass wir hier über Ismael Jakobs sprechen. Und ich habe das gar nicht mitbekommen. Also richtig, richtig cool. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für eine, wie immer, sehr schöne Runde. Und danke, dass ihr mir immer alle Bundesliga-Quervergleiche, sollten sie noch so schief sein, durchgehen lasst. Ganz herzlichen Dank an David Franchet de Pont-Lévin von 93. Danke dir, lieber David. Danke an Alex Treuker von vivalaliga.de unter anderem. Danke, lieber Alex.
Sehr gerne.
Und danke an Marius Seucke von Serie Amore. Wann startest du dein Portal, Marius? Das ist die einzige Frage. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank auch für die Einladung.
Und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit der Premier League. Hallo, Jogi Hebel. Schön, dass du da bist für die Premier League.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, wir wollen jetzt sprechen über die wichtigsten Themen aus der Premier League. Und wir küren natürlich noch die Awards und die Matches to Watch. Ein paar Ligen haben wir ja schon hinter uns. Jetzt geht es nach England. Mit was willst du denn anfangen? Du hast uns Arsenal gegen City und Liverpool gegen Brighton mitgebracht.
Ja, darfst du dir aussuchen. Das kleinere Thema, oder das wahrscheinlich kontroversere wäre jetzt erst mal Liverpool, weil es da eine Vorgeschichte gibt mit Jürgen Klopp. Wenn du dich daran erinnerst. Ich glaube, ich fange damit einfach mal an. Das haben wir im Podcast auch so gemacht tatsächlich. Ich finde das sehr witzig. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das Spiel gesehen hast, aber es gibt zwei kuriose Situationen. Einmal Elfmeter, den Liverpool bekommt. Dann gibt es viele, die sagen, Doppelbestrafung hätte eigentlich hergemusst, weil klare Torchance verhindert. Da war dann sehr witzig, dass Jürgen Klopp auf der Pressekonferenz danach gefragt worden ist. Er meinte, er habe auch gehört, dass das so ist. Wer ist denn dafür? Dann haben fünf Journalisten schon mal die Hand gehoben. Da gibt es schon Leute, die das irgendwie erharten. Und dann, als er fünf Sekunden später gefragt worden ist, auf der anderen Seite gab es einen Handelfmeter. Wird schon von Daik. Was war denn da los? Ja, Handelfmeter. Ach, das meinte die Zerbi, als er mich da so anschrie. Er hat irgendwas von Penalty gerufen. Ja, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Das hat er dann logischerweise nicht mitbekommen. Und das ist halt schon irgendwie witzig gewesen. Musste ich sehr schmunzeln, weil das halt Jürgen Klopp einfach eines Bestes in seiner momentanigen Rolle ist.
Aber was war denn die Vorgeschichte jetzt zu Liverpool? Also meinst du mit der Vorgeschichte jetzt quasi der fälschlich aberkannte Treffen?
Dass das momentan einfach in aller Munde ist bei ihm. Wir haben im Podcast auch darüber philosophiert. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn er zuvor diesen Ermittler nicht bekommen hätte, und wenn das nicht schon schrittlich gewesen wäre, dann hätte er richtig vom Leder gelassen. Aber so ist das Spiel unentschieden ausgegangen. Er konnte jetzt nicht so, sonst wäre er endgültig durchgedreht. Weil er hat schon Backlash bekommen in England. Logischerweise sind 19 von 20 Fanlagern gegen Liverpool. Da ruft er schnell mal so, dass er immer kloppt. Deswegen hat es auch nicht leicht. Er hat recht, aber du kennst ihn ja auch. Er macht es immer ein bisschen laut.
Wie ist das sportlich zu bewerten? Brighton ist ja ein Überraschungsteam. Aktuell 16 Punkte, 6. Platz. Liverpool mit 17 Punkten, nur einen davor. Aber man hat noch den Anschluss zur Spitze. Drei Punkte Rückstand auf die Tabellenführer. Wer das ist, lasse ich gleich noch raus. Und jetzt eben dieses 2 zu 2. War das auch leistungsgerecht? Absolut.
Und es zeigt bei beiden Mannschaften Stärken und Schwächen. Dass Brighton mit allen mitspielen kann, ist respektabel. Dass es funktioniert, ist respektabel. Hat die Woche davor nicht funktioniert, aber jetzt funktioniert es wieder. Das zeigt, dass sie immer in einem Spiel eine Chance haben. Ich habe nachgeschaut vorher noch mal, Expected Goals auf beiden Seiten 2,3 zu 2,4 oder so. Das sagt ja auch eine Menge aus. Liverpool ist nach wie vor nicht so stabil hinten, wie sie es gerne hätten. Brighton kann jeden Gegner nerven. Jetzt kannst du dir aussuchen, was von beiden schöner ist. Liverpool ist immer für 2 Tore gut, aber das Problem ist, sie sind vorne wie hinten.
Was hat damit der Umbruch zu tun? Wir haben schon mal darüber gesprochen, dass Liverpool das Mittelfeld umgestellt hat. Das sieht man ja, wenn man sich die Ausstollerung anguckt. In dem Spiel waren es jetzt wieder Sorbislaimek, Alistair und Elliott. Wir haben das ja schon thematisiert. Hängt damit dann auch diese defensive Schwäche zusammen, dass man manchmal ein Tor zu viel kassiert?
Das ist die Frage. Das war ja letztes Jahr schon so. Das ist das große Problem, dass es letztes Jahr schon so war. Und dass die Abwehr fast unangetastet ist. Sie haben versucht, mit Trent Alexander-Arnold eher invers zu spielen, um dort vielleicht mehr den Gegner aufhalten zu können. Mehr in der Restverteidigung zu haben. Hat auch nicht funktioniert. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch skeptisch. Vor allem, ich habe das in der Vorbereitung schon gesehen. Das ist immer noch so. Bälle zwischen Innenverteidiger und Außenverteidiger. Die gehen fast wie ein Messer durch Butter. Also wirklich. Da haben sie so Probleme, das zu verteidigen. Und auch gerade, wenn es im Tempo gegen Sturz schnell geht, haben die so große Probleme, das zu verteidigen. Und es ist immer so ein Fehler da drinnen, wo du dir sagst, okay, die Innenverteidiger sind nicht mehr so dynamisch, wie sie es mal waren. Und das ist das große Problem. Also sie haben ja angefangen, das ist ja ganz witzig, die Entwicklung, sie haben angefangen, die Abwehr umzubauen, dass diese Verletzungsprobleme in der Abwehr waren vor drei Jahren in der Corona-Saison. Dann haben sie angefangen, jetzt die Offensive umzubauen, mit Rackbo, mit David Nunes, mit Jota, mit Diaz und so. Und jetzt war eigentlich das Mittelfeld dran. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, danach wäre man eigentlich fertig. Aber jetzt geht es hinten wieder los.
Und Alisson Becker sah jetzt nicht immer gut aus in dem Spiel gegen Brighton, oder?
Ja, ich mag den sehr gerne. Jürgen Klopp sagt ja immer, ich habe letztens das Zitat gelesen, Alisson hat uns den Popo gerettet. Das stimmt wirklich, das tut er sehr, sehr häufig. Der kriegt so viel um die Ohren, dass er auch einmal daneben langt. Aber dem würde ich jetzt nicht die große Schuld geben. Die lassen den schon sehr oft alleine. Das muss man schon sagen.
Und auf der anderen Seite, der Serbi ist in aller Munde. Also Brighton dementsprechend ja auch. Es überrascht einen jetzt ja nicht mehr, dass Brighton so gut mithalten kann. Und man weiß ja inzwischen auch schon, was man bekommt. Also Brighton-Spiele lohnen sich immer anzugucken. Ich glaube, das ist so eine einfache Faustregel, die aktuell gilt. Hat sich da nochmal was verändert bei Brighton? Wird den jetzt vielleicht auch anders begegnet von den Gegnern? Eigentlich würde man ja erwarten, dass jetzt dann im zweiten, dritten Jahr, wo man so erfolgreichen Fußball spielt, die Gegner vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders spielen gegen Brighton.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar. Ich glaube zum Beispiel Aston Villa hat es ja letzte Woche sehr, sehr clever gemacht. Die haben halt wirklich einfach, ich sage es mal wieder, Una Emery ist für mich einer der besten Matchplan-Trainer der Welt, wenn nicht sogar für mich der Beste, weil der einfach genau hergeht und sagt, ihr habt das, dann nehmen wir euch weg und wir finden schon einen Weg. Und das ist einfach das Pragmatischste wahrscheinlich gegen die, weil dann nimmst du es ihnen wirklich. Und Liverpool spielt natürlich mit. Die denken sich, wir sind Liverpool und die werden natürlich ein paar Dinge anpassen, aber im Grunde genommen wollen die schon nach vorne spielen, weil sonst nimmst du ja ihnen selbst die Stärke, deren DNA. Wenn wir gerne zu einem anderen Spiel kommen, wo ein Trainer das getan hat, und das schadet dir ja dann selber, wenn du dich deine eigenen Schwächen beraubst. Dementsprechend glaube ich schon, dass Liverpool, ich dachte, schauen wir mal, wer stärker ist, und dann haben wir halt so ein Spiel bekommen. Also es war richtig, richtig, richtig schön anzusehen.
Aber würdest du sagen, bei Brighton hat sich nochmal was verändert jetzt im Vergleich zur letzten Saison?
Also ich hab jetzt nicht so mega, also ich hab das letzte Spiel jetzt nicht so gesehen. Aber ich hab mit Benny letztens nochmal gesprochen, der meint halt schon, ja, so kleinere Anpassungen gibt es schon. Aber im Grunde genommen ist es noch immer Plan A. Und dem ziehen sie einfach durch. Und das ist, ja, sie haben in der letzten Podcast gesagt, sie haben den schönsten Plan A der Welt, aber sie haben halt nur Plan A.
Genau, danke. Werde ich hier natürlich auch verlinken in den Show Notes die neue Sendung auf Twitch, die ihr sehen könnt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber dann lass doch mal noch auf das zweite Spiel kommen, das werden bestimmt auch viele mitbekommen haben. Arsenal gegen Manchester City und tatsächlich Arsenal gewinnt mit 1 zu 0. Aber da musst du mir jetzt helfen, Jogi. Ich habe dieses Spiel nicht sehen können, weil ich ja immer mit meinem Bundesliga-Quatsch beschäftigt bin. Ich habe das Ergebnis gesehen. Dann habe ich mir Statistiken angesehen und habe gesehen, dass Arsenal 12 zu 4 Schüsse, da haben sie wirklich die Schotten dichtgemacht gegen City. Dann habe ich die Expected Goals gesehen, und da war aber City so leicht vor Arsenal. Also sprich, in diesen 4 Schüssen müssen unglaublich gute Chancen mit dabei gewesen sein. Wie war es denn jetzt, dieses Spiel?
Ja, es war... Ich habe auch was ab der zweiten Hälfte, weil ich hatte zuvor noch ein Spiel und bin erst nach Hause. Ich habe es erst ab der Halbzeitpause gesehen, ein bisschen davor. Aber ich persönlich war von Manchester City sehr enttäuscht, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Allein die Aufstellung... Wir haben danach diese Frage gestellt bekommen, weil ja, Arteta wechselt 3-mal ein. Oder 4-mal ein, glaube ich. Und diese 4 sind an dem entscheidenden Tor beteiligt. Also langer Ball, Ablage, weitergelegt und rein. Das waren genau die 4. Und dann haben sie sich die Frage gestellt, hat Arsenal den Sieg mal wieder eingewechselt oder macht diese Formulierung überhaupt Sinn? Und wir haben dann eigentlich die Frage weitergegeben an Benny und an Flo Blüchel, Scout bei Arsenal gewesen. Und wir haben uns so ein bisschen rumphilosophiert. Und Flo meinte, ich glaube nicht, dass dort der Sieg eingewechselt worden ist bei Arsenal, sondern ich glaube eher, dass Pep die Nürnlage aufgestellt hat. Und das ist glaube ich das sehr interessante daran, weil wenn du dir das anschaust, er hat nominell jetzt in der Führerkette nichts anderes gemacht, aber taktisch schon. Also Kyle Walker, der ja eigentlich den inversen Innenverteidiger gelernt, gefühlt erfunden hat, spielte plötzlich die Linie rauf und runter. Und man merkte, dass es einfach nicht mehr so kann, dass es auch nicht sein Ding ist, sondern dass er einfach viel, viel besser ist, wenn er dann eben aus der Tiefe kommt und wenn er dort eben im Aufbau beteiligt sein kann und dann auch mal in der Restverteidigung einen abgrätschen kann. Das sind seine Stärken. Er ist aber die Linie rauf und runter. Er hat mit Rico Luis im Mittelfeld gespielt, das ist ein Außenverteidiger. Und jetzt wird es am allerinteressantesten, ja, Rodri ist gesperrt, aber er spielt auf der 6 mit Bernardo Silva. Und das sind natürlich schon so Dinge, also ich finde, das passt einfach nicht. Gerade gegen Arsenal mit dem Declan Rice, der hatte ich allein schon mal physisch statt dem Überlegen, da hat er schon ein paar Duelle gewonnen. Da konnte Bernardo nichts dafür, der hat auch nicht schlecht gespielt, aber ich persönlich würde mir eher denken, es fehlt de Bruyne und es fehlt Rodri. Dann versuche ich wenigstens Bernardo Silva als den kreativeren Part zu verwenden. Und für die 6 muss ich mir etwas überlegen. Dann stelle ich da vielleicht, keine Ahnung, er hat ja genügend Leute und das wird da vielleicht noch etwas Kreatives einfallen. Du hast Matthäus Nulisch für fast 60 Millionen geholt und den lässt auf der Bank sitzen. Du hast letzte Saison Kevin Phillips für 40 Millionen geholt und den lässt er auf der Bank sitzen. Dass du denen nicht vertraust und dass du sagst, Bernardo Silva wird Rodri sein, also das glaube ich ist nett gedacht auf den ersten Blick, aber hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und nach vorne, muss ich sagen, waren sie so unkreativ, es ist lang nicht mehr Hauk-Fußball und Tiki-Taka, das ist auch vorbei, aber das war so einfach auf Absicherung bedacht, um Arsenal keine Räume zu geben, dass sie nach vorne überhaupt nichts hinbekommen. Expected Goals, Erling Haaland 0,00. Das sagt eigentlich auch eine Menge.
Das ist schon eine interessante Entwicklung bei City. Wie ist das denn? Pep Guardiola fällt ja wegen einer Rücken-OP, kann er eine ganze Weile nicht an der Seitenlinie stehen, war er jetzt in dem Spiel wieder richtig am Couchen oder saß er wieder auf der Tribüne?
Nee, das war jetzt schon das vierte und fünfte Mal da. Ich hab das erste Mal gehabt, als er zurückkam. Ich glaub, gegen West Ham kam er zurück bei mir. Das müsste vor ein paar Wochen gewesen sein.
Da sieht man mal, dass ich das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen habe. Aber wo steht denn jetzt dann City deiner Meinung nach? Ich meine, die Bilanz ist natürlich immer noch gut. Zwei Niederlagen, sechs Siege. Natürlich nervt das jetzt dann, dass man auch dieses Spiel dann auch die Art und Weise, wie man es verloren hat. Aber es ist ja alles sehr, sehr eng. Also Tottenham, aktuell Tabellenführer, Arsenal. Punkt gleicht, beide 20 Punkte, beide eine Plus-10er-Tor-Differenz. Dann Manchester City, die haben plus 18 Punkte. Liverpool haben 17 Punkte. Und Aston Villa und Brighton, die könnte man jetzt rein theoretisch noch dazurechnen. Die sind vier Punkte dahinter. Das ist jetzt natürlich dann wahrscheinlich eher Makulatur. Da wird noch eine Lücke aufgehen. Aber die oberen vier sind sehr eng beieinander.
Wo steht da City im Vergleich mit den anderen dreien?
Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht schlimm, dass es so ist, wie es ist. Ich könnte die Schriftliche suchen, müsste jetzt echt ein bisschen kramen im Laptop. Aber es ist bei City eigentlich traditionell so, dass sie in den ersten 13 Spielen, das ist immer so der Cut, wo man in einer englischen Zeitung die Vergleiche gemacht hat, die lassen immer Punkte in den ersten 13 Spielen. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt schlimm. Die Überraschung war, das habe ich ja immer gesagt, auch in den Spielen, die Überraschung ist, dass City die ersten sechs Spiele oder was es waren, gewonnen hat. Das war die Überraschung, dass sie so rauskommen. Auch da ist es noch nicht gerollt, dass man sagen könnte, wow, das ist ja unglaublich, was die spielen. Und trotzdem haben sie die Spiele gewonnen. Das ist die Gefahr jetzt für alle anderen, dass wenn City jetzt schon nicht rollt, dass sie nie tun. Die kommen nie gut raus. Die haben ja immer am Schluss diese 11 Spiele Siegesserie, 10 Spiele Siegesserie. Aber dass sie am Anfang schon die Siegesserie haben, das sollte wirklich allen Angst machen. Wenn es dann so weitergeht, dann wissen wir auch, wie es bei Guardiola laufen kann. Dann sind die im März schon Meister. Und hatten wir ja in deiner geliebten Bundesliga das Öfteren. Also insofern, das gibt es. Insofern, in unserer Geliebten muss man sagen, ich bin ja da nicht raus. Aber das ist dann eben das, wo ich mir wirklich Sorgen gemacht habe um die Premier League, dass City wieder weglaufen wird. Dass die jetzt so eine kleine Delle haben, finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, ehrlich gesagt. Ich meine, gegen Arsenal, die hätten noch unentschieden spielen können. Wenn Rotir dabei gewesen wäre, glaube ich, wäre es ein ganz anderes Spiel gewesen, weil der liegt Arsenal gar nicht. Das ist einfach der beste Sechser der Welt. Ich bleibe dabei, auch wenn es... Da gibt es ja auch Kritiker, die sagen, momentan ist er ein bisschen über drüber, wie auch immer. Ich liebe diesen Spieler. Und ich glaube, mit dem wäre es ganz anders ausgegangen. Dann hätte Bernardo Silva eine andere Rolle spielen können. Dann hätte Calvo keine andere Rolle spielen können, weil das hat ja seine Gründe, dass alles so verschoben worden ist. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass City dann eine Chance gehabt hätte, zumindest einen Punkt zu holen. Und dann hätte keiner darüber diskutiert. Und vor allem, man muss auch sagen, der Schuss von Martinelli war ein abgefälschtes Ding. Also das ist reiner Zufall, dass der reingeht am Ende des Tages. Und dann gewinnen die jetzt und alle sagen, ah, das hat City geknackt. Ja, stimmt, aber hätte auch anders ausgehen können. So ist es jetzt nicht, dass man jetzt sagen müsste, das war ein klarer Asen-Sieg. So war es jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Ja, wenn du ein Power-Ranking aus diesen vier Teams machen würdest, also dann City auf eins, so wie ich es jetzt rausgehört habe, oder wie wäre die Reihenfolge aktuell?
Wenn wir zwei Nierlagen jetzt am Stück, da bin ich natürlich jetzt echt schwer. Dann glaube ich, muss man eigentlich, also ich persönlich muss sagen, so Hardfacts-Power-Ranking ist vielleicht ein anderes, aber so gefühlt Power-Ranking Nummer eins für mich totnehmen, weil es einfach momentan das Team ist, wenn du dir so ein Smiley vorstellst. Das ist ein grüner Smiley mit einem Grinsen. Und den hat Tottenham einfach momentan als einziges Team. Bei denen läuft wirklich alles und weit besser als ich zu dem Zeitpunkt glaube ich auch gedacht und geplant hatten. Deswegen würde ich so, aber wir alle wissen, vom Kader her ist Tottenham jetzt nicht das Beste. Deswegen, aber von der Form her, von dem wie die momentan spielen, von dem wie die momentan drauf sind, würde ich jetzt einfach mal Tottenham sagen. Dann vielleicht Arsenal, dann Liverpool würde ich jetzt auch da oben mitnehmen. Das sind die so, diese vier sind es einfach momentan.
Okay, Tottenham und Arsenal ja auch die einzigen beiden Teams, die noch umgeschlagen sind in der Liga.
Eine Sache haben wir noch. Bei diesem Spiel gab es ja auch noch Kovacic, der eigentlich hätte rot sehen müssen. Da haben die Engländer mal wieder ihr Schiedsrichterproblem der ganzen Welt offenbart. Also Kovacic, Foul, Odegaard. Da diskutieren Leute schon über Serious Foul Play, also ein echtes Foul Spiel. Wird sich angeschaut. Es gibt eine gelbe Karte. Fünf Minuten später, weiß nicht mehr, nagelt mich jetzt bitte nicht fest, aber haut er Decan Rice um, Ball ist weg, er haut ihm hinten diese voll in die Knöchel rein von hinten. Und dafür gibt es gar nichts. Also selbst wenn man sagen würde, okay, das erste war keine rote Karte, beides waren gelbe Karten. Also Kovacic hätte auf jeden Fall bis zur Halbzeitpause nicht mehr auf dem Feld stehen dürfen. Und da, glaube ich, hat, muss man auch sagen, hat City wahrscheinlich auch Glück, in Anführungszeichen, dass sie verloren haben. Das wären auch meine riesen Shitstorm gewesen in Richtung der Schiedsrichter, in Richtung von Manchester City, weil das waren beides für mich gelbe Karten. Ganz ganz klar. Die erste war, es gibt Hartleine, die werden sagen, das ist schon eine rote Karte. Da würde ich jetzt nicht mitgehen in der Premier League bei so einem Spiel um diese Uhrzeit, bei diesem Spielstand zu dieser, ja, bei dieser Spieldauer von viertel Stunde oder wie auch immer. Da würde ich jetzt nicht machen, aber beides insgesamt sind als gelbe Karten zu bewerten. Da haben wir echt nur mal Glück. Die Schiedsrichter-Gilde hat momentan echt ein Problem dort.
Aber ist es denn möglich, in der Premier League gelbe Karten auch zu reviewen, oder ist es da wie in Deutschland das nur Platz verweise? Entsprechend konnte dann Michael Oliver da nicht mehr geholfen werden vom VAA.
Ja, da lässt sich auch Ungern helfen, das ist das Problem.
Als ich es gesagt habe, dachte ich mir, war das nicht derjenige, der immer bei seiner Entscheidung bleibt.
Das siehst du dem schon an, dass er sich denkt, was wollt ihr eigentlich? Das ist sehr ignorant, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das muss man ihm auch zugute halten, der ist immer ein Hardliner. Der pfeift sehr wenig und gibt auch sehr spät esgäbe Karten. Deswegen, das ist seine Linie. Der hat nichts verlassen, was man nicht kennt oder so.
Okay, wieder eine Schiedsrichter-Kontroverse. Dann lass mal zu den Awards kommen. MVP, Anzang Hero und Moment des Spieltags.
MVP würde ich sagen, der Glen Rice. Weil er dieses Spiel wirklich definiert und dominiert. Und hat gezeigt, dass er auf diesem Niveau Arsene einfach noch mal ein Stückchen besser macht. Deswegen würde ich sagen, der Glen Rice, der geht manchmal so wenig unter, weil er nur ein zentral defensiver Mittelfeldspieler ist. Ich habe Gerüchte gehört, dass sie in der Vorbereitung überlegt haben, ich glaube, der ist vielleicht doch nicht der Problemlöser. Wir sollten uns einen Plan B überlegen. Der ist momentan sowas von der Problemlöser. Der ist richtig gut und ist so wichtig. Wir haben es gesehen, in dem Spiel gegen Tottenham, als der raus war, war die ganze Sicherheit weg. Und das, glaube ich, war schon sehr wichtig in diesem Spiel, weil Arsene eben das gegeben hat, was gegen City sonst immer gefehlt hat. Würde ich sagen, Kieron Trippier. Der hat jetzt schon sechs Vorlagen in dieser Saison, wenn ich mich alles täusche, oder fünf. Ich hatte das Spiel eben West Ham gegen Newcastle und der hat wieder ein Spiel gemacht. Der gibt Vorlage wiedergegeben. Der ist an allem beteiligt, was kreativ ist. Nach hinten super clever. Überhaupt einer der kreativsten Außenverteidiger, mit die meisten Chancen kreiert, überhaupt in der Premier League, aber die meisten Außenverteidiger. Der spielt so eine gute Saison und ist einfach auch so ein guter Fußballer und auch ein guter Typ für diese Mannschaft. Und das, glaube ich, haben wirklich die wenigsten auf dem Schirm, was der da momentan spielt. Vielleicht der Premier League-Fan, vielleicht nicht so. Und deswegen sage ich, das ist absolut der Anzang-Hero, weil gerade das Außenverteidiger sowieso.
Ja, hat ja auch eine Rolle gespielt beim 4 zu 1 gegen PSG. Das war natürlich ein Ergebnis, das haben wahrscheinlich viele mitbekommen. Jetzt unter der Woche war das, in der letzten Woche. Und welchen Moment des Spieltags hast du? Ich hoffe, es hat nicht mit Schiedsrichtern zu tun.
Da würde ich tatsächlich einfach wirklich diesen Moment nehmen mit Martinelli. Dass der das Tor macht und wie Arsenal dann gepoppt ist, das glaube ich, muss man schon sagen. Die haben jetzt so lange nicht gewonnen gegen Manchester City. Guardiola hat so lange nicht besiegt. Dann outtügt die Geschichte dann noch drum, dass es dann auch Querelen unten an den Katakomben gab. Dass der Standard-Trainer von Arsenal sich so ein bisschen demonstrativ hingestellt hat, die Hände in den Rücken, so quasi euch gebe ich die Hand heute nicht. Man merkt da wirklich, was da zwischen den Mannschaften momentan für eine Spannung ist. Auch wenn die beiden, Guardiola und Arteta, sich mögen, brauchen wir nicht reden. Die sind die einzigen beiden, die wirklich in die Katakomben gehen und die Klappe halten, weil sie wollen einfach gar nicht verführt werden. Aber man merkt, was da los ist zwischen diesen beiden Teams. Man merkt auch, was zwischen den Fanlagern los ist. Und diese Rivalität, City gegen Liverpool, das war die Rivalität der letzten fünf Jahre. Das ist geswitcht. Also mittlerweile schon Arsenal gegen Man City. Das ist momentan die beiden größten Teams, muss man schon sagen. Und dass Arsenal das nach Ewigkeit mal gewinnen konnte und was das auch mit den Emirates gemacht hat, ist, glaube ich, schon etwas historisches gewesen, was wir, glaube ich, aus der deutschen Sicht jetzt gar nicht so sehen können. Aber wie die abgegangen sind, die Fans, glaube ich, für die ist das etwas ganz Besonderes gewesen. Und natürlich auch für die ganze Saison jetzt, weil Ars natürlich City jetzt wirklich geschlagen hat. Was macht das mit Arsenal? Was macht das mit City? Kommen die zurück? Erst recht. Wie reagiert Garniola drauf taktisch? Natürlich auch das, dass City das jetzt nicht gewonnen hat, ist natürlich auch gut für die Tabelle, weil jetzt sind die alle enger zusammen. Deswegen, das, glaube ich, ist jetzt einfach nur ein Spiel gewesen. Aber für uns alle als Fußballfans ist es das Allerbeste, weil jetzt diese Saison, glaube ich, erst richtig losgeht. Weil jetzt sind jetzt alle so, jeder hat mal einige Watsch bekommen, so gefühlt. Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz gut für die Liga, weil jetzt einfach natürlich alle so auf einem Level sind.
Außer die Spurs und Arsenal, aber das wird auch noch kommen.
Ja, aber Arsenal hat ja Gefühl da auch schon eine bekommen, weil, ich meine, Nortten David nicht gewonnen nach zweifacher Führung. So meinte ich, jeder hat schon irgendwie ein Spiel mal abgegeben, wo du dir denkst, boah, das wäre eigentlich unnötig gewesen. Und das hat Arsenal auch schon, die haben das mit Sicherheit als Niederlage gesehen, nach zweifacher Führung. Und Storzino verliert den Ball vor dem eigenen Strafraum und der Gegner rennt alleine drauf zu. Also das war eine Niederlage. Auch wenn es mit Punkte von ging, aber gefühlt war das eine Niederlage.
Ja, hast du recht. Das macht richtig Bock, danach der Länderspielpause wieder reinzugucken. Was sind denn die Matches, die uns dann nicht entgehen lassen sollten?
Ja, da hast du mich auf wirklich kalt erwischt. Aber jetzt kann ich natürlich einen ganz einfachen Call machen, weil der Mercyside-Derby Liverpool gegen Everton ist natürlich immer etwas Besonderes. Chelsea gegen Arsenal ist danach auch noch auch interessant. Und dann natürlich auch, das habe ich sogar, glaube ich, wenn ich alles täusche, Manchester City gegen Brighton. Ich hatte das letzte Saison kurz vor Schluss. Das war taktisch eines der interessantesten Spiele, die ich jemals gesehen habe, weil De Zerbi gegen Guardiola. Die beiden schätzen sich, die beiden mögen sich. De Zerbi ist ja extra mal aus Italien nach München gereist, um Guardiola bei Bayern München einfach zuzuschauen. Da war er noch Amateurtrainer. Die beiden lieben sich über allem. Und die beiden jetzt gegeneinander zu sehen, muss ich schon sagen, das ist immer interessant und ist taktisch der absolute Oberkracher. Frenzi Arsenal immer. Aber so ein Spiel hast du halt immer jede Woche in der Premier League, dass einer großer gegen den anderen großen spielt. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, immer interessant, aber es ist auch nicht so spektakulär. Und Merseyside-Darby ist, glaube ich, auch so unausgeglichen wie seit ewigen Jahren nicht mehr. Aber genau dann wird es immer gefährlich in solchen Darbys.
Genau, das wollte ich schon sagen.
Wir haben so viel da drin, also es ist wirklich sehr interessant. Jede Woche so.
Also, das wird schön, wenn es weitergeht am 21. und 22. Oktober. Jogi, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank dir. Und sag doch nochmal kurz, wo kann man dich denn jetzt bei RondoTV sehen? Was ist RondoTV und so weiter und so fort?
Vielen Dank dafür. Also, das heißt, wir sind bei Twitch. Schrägstrich das RondoTV. Es ist eine Fußball-Sendung, die wir jetzt ins Leben gerufen haben, mit Benny Grund, Videoanalyste eines Bundesligisten. Ich glaube, er mag es ziemlich so gern, wenn man sagt, wann wo. Flo Blüchel, ehemaliger Scout von Arsenal, ehemaliger Scout Bayern München, der momentan sich einem privaten Projekt widmet, eben auch uns. Und das ist natürlich überragend, weil du hast einen, der spieltaktisch die Welt erklären kann. Du hast einen, der individualtaktisch oder vom Spielerprofiler die Welt erklären kann. Und du hast mit Uli und mir zwei Holzköpfe, die das einfach versuchen, irgendwo rein zu pressen. Und die jetzt auch schon mal ein paar Spiele gesehen haben. Das ist, glaube ich, insgesamt schon eine coole Combo. Wir machen Reactions auf Spiele, Reactions auf Pressekonferenzen. Wir schauen einfach mal ein Spiel an, so Watchalongs. Wir reden aber auch einfach über Themen, machen irgendwie über Vereine. Zum Beispiel, letztens ging es um die Hertha. Wir haben einfach erklärt, was macht die Hertha momentan, was macht sie falsch, was macht sie richtig. Und so Teamprofile und was könnte besser sein. Dann fragt man Flo wieder, welcher Spieler würde da reinpassen. Das ist einfach so, versuchen die Expertisen auszunutzen. Und er macht mega Spaß und wächst stetig, dauert immer so ein bisschen auf Twitch. Aber du bist auch gerne mal eingeladen. Ich soll dich von allen grüßen und dich gerne einladen.
Ja, ich weiß zwar nicht, wie ich da jetzt noch reinpasse, aber ich komm gerne mal und grüße sehr herzlich zurück. Also es wird alles verlinkt werden. Danke dir, Oli, für deine Zeit. Sehr gerne. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Wie immer geht der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und auch kleine Beträge helfen. Und auch wenn ihr nur die Ligatur zum Beispiel hört, dann überlegt euch doch, welchen Wert hat das denn für euch, dass wir hier wöchentlich über 2. Männerbundesliga und die europäischen Top-Ligen der Männer sprechen. Und diesen Wert lasst ihr uns dann zukommen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.